una entrada triunfal con fuegos
artificiales bajo los gritos de macro no
presidente así comenzó este gran y único
meeting de campaña de manuel ma con una
semana antes de la primera vuelta de
manuel amat con que se dirigió a cerca
de 30.000 personas aquí en este en esta
arena en another estaba el pleno del
gobierno así como su familia y su señora
esposa la norma como comienzo
refiriéndose a la guerra en ucrania
luego para hacer un balance de sus cinco
años de gobierno en especial los logros
en materia de empleo y luego volvió a
dar a conocer los diferentes ejes de su
programa presidencial para los próximos
cinco años se anunció además que la
salud mental sería una de las
prioridades de su gobierno y que la
lucha por la igualdad entre hombres y
mujeres sería de nuevo la gran causa
nacional así como ya lo hizo durante su
primera el quinquenio primero el marco
hizo un llamado a la unidad y se dirigió
especialmente a la la izquierda de su
gobierno que será determinante en caso
de llegar a la segunda web